c'était hier dans un parc populaire de
la capitale suédoise stockholm autant du
corona dit l'homme qui filme un peu
perplexe et il n'est pas le seul
contrairement au reste de l'europe
le pays a décidé de ne pas confiné sa
population et le swing funk les
coiffeurs et tous les commerces sont
ouverts et les terrasses remplie comme
si de rien n'était mais le pays est bel
et bien frappé par le virus selon les
derniers chiffres la suède vient de
passer la barre des 2000 morts comparé à
ses proches voisins
ça représente 20 décès par 100 1000
habitants contre 3 en finlande et en
norvège et six au danemark
on en est à 14 au québec les hôpitaux
suédois n'ont jamais été submergés ni
les services de réanimation et le pic de
l'épidémie serait passé depuis deux
semaines déjà
la suède a misé sur la responsabilité
des citoyens qui ne doivent pas se
rassembler à plus de 50
mais pas de confinement obligatoires
seuls les plus de 70 ans sont censés
rester à l'écart interdiction de leur
rendre visite
il faut observer une distance entre les
clients dans les restaurants sous peine
d'être fermée et il y a moins de table
sur les terrasses des bars si les
universités ont fermé pas les écoles
pour une raison simple en laissant les
enfants en classe les parents peuvent
continuer à travailler sans être tentés
de les confier aux grands parents c'est
la phrase que répète le gouvernement se
débarrasser du coronavirus c'est un
marathon pas un sprint en d'autres
termes et y ait des mesures plus douces
seront acceptés plus longtemps moins de
restrictions et un bilan enviable pour
d'autres pays européens la france
l'italie et l'espagne sont à bien plus
de 20 morts par cent mille habitants
mais les démographies sont différentes
la plus grande ville de suède compte à
peine un million d'habitants et le virus
à révéler des inégalités
les immigrés qui vivent davantage de
promiscuité ont payé le plus lourd
tribut que le reste de la population
d'ici le 1er mai on estime qu'un quart
des suédois auront contracté lakovic 19
mai le vrai bilan de la méthode suédoise
devra attendre encore plusieurs mois
si mathieu prost radio canada montréal